why
now for those of you that recall our
discussion about Civil War this
discussion on the tie-ins is going to be
very similar to that in the sense that
we're not going to go in depth and to
everything that's going on with
spider-man at this particular point in
time if you recall our discussion about
Civil War for example we had talked
about Heroes for Hire but all we had
done when we talked about Heroes for
Hire is that the Heroes for Hire had
been contracted by Reed Richards and the
remaining members of Reed Richards inner
circle of the Avengers to attempt to
find a way to capture Captain America
and so that's what we're going to do
here with our discussion on spider-man
we're only going to stick with the
elements of the story that pertain to
original sin now with the way the story
kicks off there's one thing that I want
to get into before we get into the main
discussion and that is the revelation of
Secrets involving various characters and
the original sin story the way that
Marvel has done this is very ambiguous
Marvel hasn't really explained exactly
how this works now maybe it's ambiguous
because of something they didn't account
for maybe it's something they simply
forgot about or maybe it's intentionally
done that way in order for the reader to
interpret it on their own but the way
that Marvel reveals secrets is strange
not everybody learns the secrets of
everybody else but some individuals do
and I think the way that Marvel has done
this is that individuals only learn
about secrets with things that pertain
to them directly for example with the
Incredible Hulk and Iron Man we learn
how it is that Bruce Banner actually
became the Incredible Hulk and Bruce
Banner is the one who initiates the
entire Incredible Hulk versus Iron Man
storyline but this is only revealed to
Bruce Banner by virtue of the fact that
the that I am and had directly
contributed to him becoming in the
Incredible Hulk which is the reason why
Bruce Banner doesn't know the secrets of
Peter Parker as we'll discuss later in
the story likewise Peter Parker doesn't
know the secrets of how it was a Bruce
Banner actually became The Incredible
Hulk and so it seems as though these
events are contained only to these
individuals and so it's not as if
everybody everywhere knows everybody
else's secrets is simply just that they
know the secrets that are relevant to
them but what we see here as the story
progresses is that Peter Parker learns
that he was not the only one bitten by
a spider that had that had been
radioactive and caused him to become
spider-man in the first place then in
fact there was somebody else there was a
girl who was bitten and the way it's
explained to us were kind of able to
piece this girl's name together and we
learned her name is Cindy moon
but this girl when she's bitten is not
able to control her abilities whereas
when Spiderman was bitten he almost
immediately went out and began to
demonstrate his powers began to capture
his powers in addition we see that this
girl Cindy moon is taken before Ezekiel
saw a character named Ezekiel and
Ezekiel says that he can help her now
we're not going to go to and depth into
Ezekiel just because we begin to getting
into territory like more loon and totems
and Peter Parker representing a spider
on a totem and all kinds of different
nonsense when it comes to Peter Parker's
character but we see that as Peter
Parker learns this once he realizes that
he's not the only person to have been
bitten by a spider and once he learns
that Ezekiel had in effect locked Cindy
moon away he goes on a hunt for her he
goes on this quest to find out who she
is and to try to find a way to locate
her in addition what we see is that once
he's able to locate this place where
she's at he breaks in and when he breaks
in of course he smashes down the door
and someone so forth but he's really
talking to himself and us at the same
time simply telling us that he's
familiar with this area he's familiar
with this location it's an old hideout
that belonged to Ezekiel and as he makes
his way into this location and automated
message appears from Ezekiel and Ezekiel
tells spider-man that if spider-man has
appeared here if spider-man has found
this location then that means that
Ezekiel was killed in a conflict with
more loon now again without going too
far in a more loon and the idea of
totems all it really was was a
circumstance whereby Peter Parker
represented an element of a totem and
that these totems were based on animals
they were based on creatures and that
more loon was on a hunt to kill each one
of these and to effectively consume them
and to take their powers and this was
how it was that Peter Parker and more
loon came into conflict but what we see
is that Ezekiel says that there's a
reason why he kept this girl hidden from
him there's a reason why he kept the two
of them separated but Peter Parker
immediately cuts them off before he can
go any further
and so we don't really know what it was
that happen from here we see Peter
Parker approaching the door whereby
Cindy moon is being kept being held and
he hollers for he calls for her and she
responds she says is anybody there and
he says yes he says this is spider-man
and she's kind of shocked to to learn
that Peter Parker is here indicating to
us that maybe there was something going
on with her character that maybe she
wasn't immediately handed over to
Ezekiel perhaps she was in the public
eye or she was part of public society
long enough to know who Peter Parker was
and again a lot of this has to do with
the time the sliding time scale of
various Marvel characters and Franklin
Richards existence of the Marvel
Universe and all kinds of different
things that go on but we see that Peter
Parker tells her that he's here to get
her out is he here too easier to save
her and that nobody should be made to
live under these kind of conditions and
Peter Parker says that he knows what the
code is
but Cindy moon says not to open it she
says that if he opens the door then more
loon will come for them what we see as a
Peter Parker is able to unlock the door
and and allow her out and almost
immediately after she is a release from
her binds she attacks Peter Parker and
she tells Peter Parker that he's killed
them all that for whatever reason
they're all going to die from here we
switched to Africa and we switched to
more loon and more loon becomes aware of
the fact that the female spider spider
woman or I guess the first official
spider woman to have ever existed in
Marvel Comics is I guess up here so
she's she's free and that she's
available for him to to attempt to
capture at this point we switched back
to speed up to Peter Parker and Cindy
moon and Peter Parker and Cindy moon are
of course continuing to fight one
another and she again tells him that
more loon is going to kill them that
more loon is going to not only attack
and kill both Peter Parker and Cindy
moon but everybody else that is a totem
along the the animal chain from here we
see that Peter Parker says that that
more loon is is not dead you know that
more loon I'm sorry that more lien is
not alive that more loon is dead but
what we also see here is that Cindy moon
is able to demonstrate powers that Peter
Parker doesn't have she is much faster
than Peter Parker is but on the off side
of this we learned that Peter Parker is
actually stronger and so it's kind of
this tray
here whereby neither of them are equal
either one is more powerful than the
other they're simply they're almost
opposite sides of the same coin but what
we see is of course once she tells him
or once Peter Parker tells her that more
lien is dead that she embraces her
freedom she embraces the fact that she's
no longer being held captive and that
she can for the most part delve into the
role that she's created for herself or
delve into the possibility of being some
kind of a superhero in addition we see
that Peter Parker tells her that she
can't simply just run around without
having any kind of a mask or any kind of
a of an outfit that she needs to be able
to keep her personal identity secret so
that she can avoid confrontations like
Peter Parker's experience with Wynn
Stacey
and so what we see is that she fashions
an outfit for herself she fashions a
costume and what she does is she goes by
the name silk now one thing I would like
you to take personal note of a very
important note of here is that I would
consider Cindy moon to again be the
first official spider woman in Marvel
Comics and the reason why is because
black hat and Julia carpenter and
various other individuals who have
adopted the role of Spider Woman have
their own powers but they're not the
result of the same spite of the bit
Peter Parker biting them this is the
first time we ever learned that the
despite of the bit Peter Parker bit
somebody else and so a lot of people
including myself will look at Cindy
munis a Cindy moon is the first official
Spider Woman to have existed in Marvel
Comics
now whether Marvel will actually do
anything with this whether or not she'll
have a short run or she'll be a
long-lasting character as something that
we don't know yet we don't really know
what the the grandiose plans are for her
character in terms of Marvel we simply
know that she's being introduced to us
as as possibly a replacement or maybe a
counterpart to Peter Parker is
spider-man in the Marvel Comics with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end and we'll
pick up with the next video when we get
into the Incredible Hulk and we talk
about the backstory involving Tony
Stark's I guess involvement with the
incredible
and how it was that Bruce Banner became
the Hulk in the first place with that
being said I will catch you guys later
you